well they say you can't go home again
but apparently you can just having a few
more bucks out of it
[Music]
so Toy Story 4 teaser trailer there's
very little for me to actually talk
about because there's almost no
substance in this which is that you know
that's not necessarily criticism it's a
teaser it's base it's practically an
announcement trailer for people who
forgot that this is a thing that is in
fact happening so you know I'm not gonna
be like it doesn't tell us anything
about this it's a teaser who cares but I
it gives me an opportunity to talk about
my thoughts on this project in general
and also what little we see I just think
shows the nakedness of the cash-grab
nature of this and look you don't have
to touch like people always mention this
when I say why would you make this movie
oh there may get the big one yes
literally every movie is made to make
money even if the director is doing a
personal passion project he still wants
it to make he or she still wants it to
make money so that they can continue to
do their job in the future and whoever's
financially backing the project
absolutely wants it to make money every
single movie is made to make money take
that as a given and stop pointing that
out to me but it's becoming really
frustrating for me because you know
especially because I guess I have my
video not long ago about you know the
Disney live-action II makes of the
animated films and a lot of people in
the comments were like Disney has no
ideas left and I'm like that's not true
at all
because Disney didn't making really good
original stuff in the last few years
I mean we're it's getting a sequel to
but frozen was good Moana was great you
know I reckon ralph was phenomenal also
getting a sequel that I don't want to
see but that that's sort of my point
Disney's know
out of juice they just can't stop
themselves when they get something that
works they can't stop themselves for
milking it but until it's not worth
being milked anymore
and Toy Story is especially aggravating
because okay first of all I don't oh I
don't like Toy Story 3 as much as a lot
of people like Toy Story 3 but I do
still like it and I do think it is
absolutely the end of that story are the
toys gone forever no they're not but the
story that was being told is over and
anything that you would want to do
you're like with similar themes just I
would much rather they do it with a new
cast and a new setting and just do new
stuff it felt like closure it felt like
a true ending to that franchise and then
here's this teaser with all them in arms
rotating around and it's just like this
slow parade of remember this and this
you liked this you spent money on this
you want to spend more money on this how
about this one and you know what little
hints we've gotten about the story don't
fill me with a ton of enthusiasm either
because like basically we've gotten two
hints about what the story's gonna
involve there is the quote-unquote new
toy which we actually see in the teaser
for ki I think they actually call him
with who is very clearly a makeshift toy
you know he wasn't built to be a toy he
was something that a kid threw together
as like an art project and is now being
used as a toy and that's not a
completely uninteresting angle like how
being a toy that comes about in that
manner might set him apart from the
other toys and maybe even put him in an
existential crisis like honestly that's
the kind of thing
I wouldn't be against exploring in one
of those Toy Story shorts that they were
doing for a while there sure I think
you're like you could get mileage you
could get 15 minutes out of that sure
the other thing is supposedly rescuing
Bo Peep who was so vital to the series
that she was completely unceremoniously
dropped from the third film with
basically a two line acknowledgement
that she had ever existed before so just
the the the cynicism that this is gonna
happen at all is just annoying and
frustrating for me now all of this said
I will ultimately probably see it
eventually I mean I've got a young kid
she's probably gonna want to see it and
had I been you know obviously I was too
young to be doing that well YouTube also
wasn't a thing I'm old but if I was in a
similar position when Toy Story 2 came
out that I am in right now I probably
would be seeing the same things about
Toy Story 2 like to be fair and then Toy
Story 2 was not only good it was better
than the first one so I am not
completely shut off from the possibility
that another Toy Story could end up
being the surprise thing that is much
better than it has any right to be and
but the thing is the the bar is kept
getting raised for this serie
particularly again I still like number 2
the best but number 3 you know was was
ambitious and was a closure narrative
and there's nothing about any of the
other sequel prod projects that have
come out of Pixar that give me a lot of
hope you know I look at something like
while frightened cripes you know I
haven't watched the car sequel so I
can't really talk about them I've seen
about half of monsters University and
then I found something else to do with
my time
and you know finding Dory and
Incredibles - neither one was awful now
the one was even close to his goods the
first one and neither one was necessary
and I think it's become very clear at
this point that Toy Story 2 I don't want
to go so far as to call it a fluke but
it was an exception we cannot look at
that and go
Pixar makes good sequels because based
off their track record they've made a
great sequel arguably - depending on
your thoughts on Toy Story 3 for one
franchise and that's kind of it
whoa hey look at that weird cut in the
middle of the thing what happened well
Pixar went and released another teaser
and again yes it is a teaser so far as
we can tell actually no definitely this
is not a clip from the actual film and
it's a little better then than what was
done before very little so this one it's
with the more I think about it the
weirder it is so this one is it's sort
of set like at a fair or carnival and
like one of those one of those carnival
games were like you know you try and
knock over milk bottles or throw darts
at balloons or whatever and win prizes
and two of those prizes two of those
kind of stuffed toys or talking with
each other now I kind of like in general
the idea of a different attitude being
held by toys that originate from
different places so like at first I was
like oh this is kind of neat you know
this more you know loose knot you know
not having this sort of oh you know we
have a responsibility kids you know they
these guys seem you know way more you
know loose a little bit carefree and
then I recognize if I some like oh my
god it's key and peele which is not a
bad thing I like key and Peele but
they're doing their doorman routine as
toys which is weird for a lot of reasons
the first
like that son kind of a dated reference
shows been off the air for what three
years now it's not exactly new and fresh
and topical and then in addition to that
it's like who's that aimed at cuz key
and peele is not a show that would be
watched by the target demographic of
this but is this their attempted like
wow I say that but then I think about
that first teaser and how it's like look
at the characters you loved and it's
very obviously trying to tell them the
heartstrings of the nostalgia crowd and
maybe this is them trying to be like oh
see we can be we can be slightly edgy
because one of the things that was
really good about the the Toy Story
franchise was it did age with its
audience basically because his audience
presumably was Andy's age and they got
the same a actor it back to play Andy
every time you can base it you're
basically you're watching the target
demographic grow up in the end the film
changed with that now like who is this
joke for like if you're starting a fresh
start presumably Andy's not in this one
anymore should we be getting a clean
break and you shouldn't still be you
know trying to appeal to what is now
eight not it'll be nine years later from
the last time you did one another nine
years out of like what would what do you
what is this who is this for and I I
don't mean to put some way because it's
probably just like a nice little fun gag
and you know the jokes aren't bad but
once I recognize the components on them
I'm just I'm just confounded by this I
don't this whole thing I don't know why
it exists I don't know why it's a thing
that we are going to be subjected to
other than money yes I understand it is
me it exists to make money I get that
but you know some studios and are able
to take the fact that this will make us
a lot of money but also find in a
artistic justification for it and you
know it'd be awesome to see this and be
suddenly surprised by
oh wow look at that they totally justify
doing a fourth one but I ain't expecting
that so that's now two teaser trailers
for Toy Story 4 what do you think about
either one of them or both of them the
existence of this thing at all whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff you can do because
there's buttons and there's links
including one to my patreon if you feel
like supporting me that way if you don't
don't worry other ways you can check out
as well but if you don't want to look at
any of them don't even worry about it
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]